TONIGHT AT 7
IT'S TIME TO TAKE CONTROL
AND OPTIMIZE YOUR HEALTH AT
REGENERATE MEDICAL CAUSE YEARS
WE STOPPED BY TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT ANTI AGING.
HI, I'M DOCTOR MAINE, THIS
MEDICAL CONCIERGE WE ARE ANTI
AGING HEALTH AND WELLNESS
CLINIC. WITH THE NUMEROUS
THINGS HERE IVY THERAPY
HORMONE REPLACEMENT ANTI AGING
SPECIFICALLY IS ACTUALLY A BIT
OF A WE CAN'T TECHNICALLY
HOWEVER ANOTHER ANOTHER TERM
FOR IT IS HEALTH AND WELLNESS
OPTIMIZATION AND THE GOAL
THERE IS IDEALLY SLOW NOW
WAYS WE CAN DO THAT ONE OF
THEM IS USING WRINKLE RELAXERS
THINGS LIKE BOTOX TO SUPPORT
MAN AND HE'S REALLY JUST HELP
BY PREVENTING THE SKIN FROM
MOVING THE OTHER OPTIONS
INCLUDE MEDICATIONS, THERE ARE
CERTAIN MAGIC THAT HELPED HER
BODY ELIMINATE CELLS THAT OUR
NOT SO HEALTHY OR ON THEIR WAY
TO BECOMING NOT SO HEALTHY WE
DO A MEDICALLY GUIDED
WEIGHT-LOSS PLANS HERE
SPECIFICALLY GEARED AT HELPING
PEOPLE LOSE THEIR FAT
CONCENTRATION IN THE BODIES
ALL WHILE MAINTAINING MUSCLE
MASS. SOME OF THE OTHER THINGS
WE CAN DO WITH GENETIC TESTING
AND WITH THE WITH THE HELP OF
GENETICS WE CAN LOOK AT
ELIMINATING CERTAIN COMPONENTS
A PERSON'S LIFESTYLE THAT FOR
THEM SPECIFICALLY MAY NOT BE
AS BENEFICIAL AS THEY COULD BE
FOR OTHER PEOPLE. AND THEN ONE
OF THE OTHER COMPONENT WE CAN
LOOK AT IS TELLING TECHNOLOGY
TODAY WE CAN ACTUALLY LOOK AT
HOW LONG A PERSON TELLING ME
CAR. THE LONGER THEY ARE. THE
LONGER A PERSON'S LIFESPAN CAN
BE AND THERE ARE MEDICATIONS
VARIOUS TREATMENT PLAN THAT
ARE AIMED SPECIFICALLY AT
INCREASING THE LENGTH OF
TELOMERES OR MAINTAINING THEIR
LIFE AND FOOD ALLERGY TESTING
IS SOMETHING WE DO WHERE WHAT
CAUSED LOW LEVELS OF
INFLAMMATION.
IN A MOST THE THE MAJOR
WHERE PEANUTS OR SHELLFISH AND
YOU TURNING TO WILL SMITH FROM
THAT MOVIE HITCH RIGHT WHERE
EVERYTHING POPS UP AND SO.
THOSE ANAPHYLACTIC
REACTIONS AND THERE ARE ALSO
LOWER LEVEL OF REACTIONS WHERE
WHAT'S HAPPENING IS THE FOOD
YOU EAT BECAUSE I HISTAMINE
RELEASE AND THAT CHRONIC LOW
LEVEL IS CAUSING CHRONIC
BODY AND PEOPLE JUST DON'T
FEEL WELL AND BY TESTING FOR
ALL THE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
FOOD ADDITIVES PRESERVATIVES
ANTIBIOTICS MOLD THERE'S A
WHOLE SPECTRUM THAT CAN BE
TESTED OVER 350 DIFFERENT
ITEMS AND WE CAN START
ELIMINATING THOSE THINGS FROM
THE DIET WE WELCOME YOU TO
COME YOU CAN CALL OFFICE AND
MAKE AN APPOINTMENT FOR A
CONSULTATION AND THAT WOULD BE
TO SIT WITH ME AND DISCUSS
WHAT'S GOING THE GOAL BEING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT WHAT THE
PINPOINT AREAS ARE AND THEN
GETTING THE AND WELLNESS
OPTIMIZATION PLAN ROLLING OUT. THANKS TO REGENERATE MEDICAL
CONCIERGE FOR SPONSORING THIS
SEGMENT...
GIVE THEM A CALL AT
702-998-8009
THANKS TO REGENERATE
SPONSORING THIS SEGMENT, GIVE